Hello, my name is
Kathryn Hurley.
I'm a developer programs
engineer at
Google for Compute Engine.
In this session, I'm going to
show you some tips and tricks
for working with Compute
Engine's metadata server.
But first, what is metadata?
Every Compute Engine instance
has metadata
associated with it.
Metadata is essentially a key
with an associated value.
Instances have a set of default
metadata values,
custom metadata assigned by
the user, and metadata
inherited from the containing
project.
Using metadata, an instance
can programmatically get
information about itself, such
as its zone, machine type, or
host name, information about
the owning project, such as
the project ID, or custom data
provided by you, the developer.
For example, if you're working
with a Hadoop-like cluster,
you can use custom metadata to
specify which node is the
master and which nodes
are the workers.
Metadata is divided
into default and
custom metadata values.
Default metadata is
defined and set by
the metadata server.
You cannot change the default
metadata values.
Examples include the project ID,
the instance zone, and the
instance host name.
On the other hand, custom
metadata allows you to define
arbitrary string key
value pairs for
your instance or project.
We'll take a look at how to do
this later in this video.
All metadata is stored
on the Compute
Engine metadata server.
The metadata server is
only available from
Compute Engine instances.
The route URL of the metadata
server is http://metadata/
computemetadata/v1beta1/.
Metadata entries are available
as subpaths
under this root URL.
Instances have access to these
entries by making an HTTP
request to the metadata
server.
Metadata entries are divided
into directories
and keys, AKA endpoints.
Directories contain other
metadata entries, while a key
maps to a specific value.
You can distinguish between the
two by the trailing slash
in the name, which indicates
a directory.
Metadata entries provide
information about both the
project and the instance.
All project metadata entries
are relative to the path
http://metadata/
computemetadata/
v1beta1/project/.
Examples include
numeric-project-ID, which is a
key providing the numeric
project ID of the project
owning the instance, and
attributes/, which is a
directory containing a list
of custom metadata values
assigned to the project.
To see a full list of project
metadata entries, see the
documentation here.
The metadata server
also provides
information about the instance.
All instance metadata entries
are relative to the path
http://metadata/
computemetadata/
v1beta1/instance/.
Examples include machine-type,
which is a key providing the
machine type of the instance,
zone, which is a key providing
the zone of the instance, and
attribute/, a directory
containing a list of custom
metadata values assigned to
the instance.
To see a full list of instance
metadata entries, see the
documentation here.
Now that you have an
understanding of the metadata
server, let's take a look
at how to use it.
Throughout the remainder of this
video, I will show you
how to retrieve default instance
metadata, including
the machine type in zone, return
all metadata from a
directory, set custom metadata
using gcutil when creating an
instance, use custom metadata
in a startup script, and
update metadata on a
running instance.
Let's take a look at how to get
default metadata from the
metadata server.
I'm going to first start up
an instance using gcutil.
gcutil is a command line tool
that allows you to manage your
Compute Engine resources.
In order to use gcutil, I'll
switch to my terminal window.
To start up an instance, I
run gcutil addinstance
metadata-demo.
I select a zone, machine
type, and image.
Keep note of the zone and
machine type I'm selecting--
us-central1-b and
n1-standard-1.
At this point, gcutil
waits until the
instance is up and running.
When the instance is running,
I can ssh into the instance
using gcutil ssh command.
Let's get the instance
machine type from the
metadata server now.
I run curl using the roots
metadata URL, plus the
instance directory, plus the
machine type key to get the
value of the machine type.
You can see the machine type
in the output here.
Now, let's get the
instance zone.
You can see the zone
in the output here.
Let's take a look at how to get
all the contents within a
metadata directory.
We can retrieve all the metadata
within a directory by
adding the recursive parameter
to the end of
the directory's URL.
For example, let's take a look
at the instance metadata by
making a curl request to the
instance directory with the
recursive parameter
set to true.
This recursive parameter can be
added to any directory URL
to retrieve all the metadata
content within that directory.
You can also set your
own custom metadata.
Custom metadata allows you to
define arbitrary key value
pairs for your instance
or project.
Custom metadata can be achieved
similarly to how the
default metadata is retrieved,
by making an HTTP request to
the metadata server.
As an example, let's
say you want to
start a Hadoop cluster.
To specify whether a node is
a master or worker, you can
create a metadata key named
role, where the values are
either set to master
or worker.
To do so, I can use the
following gcutil commands.
Notice an important flag here,
the metadata flag.
This flag allows you
to set a custom
metadata key value pair.
In this case, I'm setting the
key role to the value master.
I could instead set this key to
worker if I was starting a
worker node.
You can provide the metadata
flag as many times as you like
to set multiple metadata
key value pairs.
Once the instance has started,
I can ssh into the machine.
And let's take a look at the
custom metadata value of the
role key using curl.
You can see the value
is master.
Now that you know how to set
custom metadata, we'll take a
look at how you can use this
metadata to introduce some
logic when the instance starts
up to determine how the
instance behaves.
We can do this using something
called a startup script.
What is a startup script?
A startup script is a batch
script that runs when the
instance boots or restarts.
You specify the startup script
for the instance when the
instance is created via
the API or gcutil.
I have a startup script stored
locally in a file called
startup.sh.
Here's what the script
looks like.
The second line makes an HTTP
request to the metadata server
to retrieve the value of the
role key and assigns it to the
variable role.
The script then uses a
conditional statement to test
the value of role.
If it's equal to master, then
I am the master is printed.
And functionality specific to
the master node is run.
Note, for simplicity,
this is not shown.
If role is equal to worker, then
just a worker is printed.
And the worker code is run.
If role is some other value, an
error message is printed.
To start an instance with my
startup script, I run the
gcutil addinstance command.
Notice the flag, metadata
from file.
This flag allows me to specify
the startup script.
I set the startup-script
metadata key to startup.sh, my
local startup script.
I can also store my startup
script on cloud storage.
In this case, I changed the flag
to just metadata and used
the key startup script URL, and
specified the URL of the
file on cloud storage
as the key value.
You might be interested to know
that the startup script
is itself metadata and
can be retrieved via
the metadata server.
Once the instance has started,
I ssh into the machine.
Let's look at the value of
the role key using curl.
You can see that the
value is master.
Now let's check the output
from our startup script.
To do so, I look at the
log file found at
bar/log/google.log.
At the end of the log, you can
see that, I am the master was
printed successfully.
I'll skip going through the
steps of starting the workers
in the interest of time, since
they are essentially started
in the same manner
as the master.
Now we'll switch gears and see
how to change metadata values
on an instance that's
already running.
As a token example, let's change
the value of the role
key from master to worker.
I can use the gcutil set
instance metadata command to
update my instance's
custom metadata.
Here's the syntax
for the command.
Note the flag fingerprints.
This is a hash of
the metadata.
It must equal the current
fingerprints on the instance
before the update
can occur, as it
performs optimistic locking.
To get the current fingerprint,
I run gcutil
getinstance.
The output displays the current
metadata fingerprints.
I'll copy this value
to use in the set
instance metadata command.
Now I can run gcutil set
instance metadata to update my
role value to worker.
To confirm that this worked,
I use gcutil getinstance to
retrieve the metadata.
You can see here that the
role metadata key is
now equal to worker.
In this video, I showed you just
some of the cool things
you can do with the metadata
server, including how to
retrieve default instance
metadata, including the
machine type and zone, return
all metadata from a directory,
set custom metadata using
gcutil, use custom metadata in
a startup script, and
update metadata
on a running instance.
There are many more neat
features of the metadata
server, including the wait for
change metadata URL parameter
and custom metadata at
the project level.
Check out the documentation
for more information.